bruno attal président fondateur du
collectif touche pas à mon flic bonsoir
environ attal on a vu c'est différent
développement notamment le duplex depuis
la marche en hommage à steve qu'anaïs
haut on a vu des mots très durs on a
entendu des mots très durs vis-à-vis de
la police
quelle est votre réaction quand vous
entendez parfois même des insultes
basses et toutefois c'est tout c'est une
inversion des valeurs tout simplement
c'est à dire que ce sont ces gens là qui
ont une responsabilité dans la mort de
steve puisque quand on a des injonctions
policière on vous demande de nous
disperser on vous demande de respecter
la loi vous demande de ne pas vous
rassemblez on ne vous demande de ne pas
alcoolisé sur la voie publique de ne pas
vous droguer et qu' on ne veut pas
admettre que force doit rester à la loi
eh bien il ya des drames il ya ensuite
dans ce soir ces gens qui ont du sang
sur les mains et ils vont recommencer
ça me fait penser un peu aux rodéos vous
êtes sur une moto vous avait pas de case
et pas d'assurance la moto est volé vous
fait du rodéo et puis une voiture de
police et puis vous tombez et puis ça
fait 1 g ça fait un mois et qui est on
va jeter l'anathème sur la police
voilà donc c'est l'inversion des valeurs
total au regard des images ont tous des
8 6 dans les mains donc soit le colisée
exemple impressions de conduite bien
commencé c'est la panacée de sa motion
bien connu alors effectivement on sait
qu'il ya trois personnes qui ont été
interpellées avec notamment port d'armes
lors de cette manifestation pour vous
c'est quoi c'est un grand malentendu il
ya peut-être un petit peu de
manipulation comment vous vous
l'expliquer parce que c'est vrai qu'il
ya des jeunes voilà qui semble assez de
bonne foi pour dire la police a du sang
sur les mains
voilà on sent qu'ils sont absolument
convaincus de ce qu'ils avancent donc il
s'agit d'un malentendu pour vous
clairement mais c'est vraiment un
malentendu enfin on sait très bien que
que les jeunes ont le cerveau qu'on a
développée qu'on peut leur retour des
cerveaux comme on veut donc voilà donc
c'est très facile d'avoir comme cible
des policiers et père de famille qui
veulent j'espère leur travail qui reçoit
des boules de pétanque en l'occurrence
hier des cocktails molotov un cocktail
molotov ça se prépare
donc voilà c'est ce sont des gens qui
voulaient en découdre qui était
alcoolisé qui était drogué qui n'ont pas
respecté la loi et il n'ya comment les
gars aucun malentendu
nous nous sommes les forces de l'ordre
gendarmes policiers
on se bat pour faire appliquer la loi on
a des ordres
on est des républicains si vous avez des
boyaux en face qui se sont très très
forts en groupe et qu'ils sont voilà qui
met en danger leurs propres amis ensuite
qui vont pleurer effectivement il faut
après se regarder dans un miroir se dire
mais qu'est ce que je n'ai pas une part
de responsabilité dans la mort de ce
type
est-ce que je n'ai pas une part de
responsabilité dans cette main harrachi
moi je peux vous dire qu'ils devraient
mieux se regarder dans une dans un
miroir ces gens là simplement
alors c'est vrai que le parquet de
rennes a tranché le jeune homme est bien
tombé dans la loire au moment de
l'intervention de la police et non avant
est ce que ce type d'information est ce
que ça met de l'huile sur le feu selon
vous j'étais pas présent et c'est le
commissaire je crois qu'il ya une
initiative comme un de lancer les dés
lacrymogènes encore une fois nous en
fonctionnaires de police on doit
toujours penser à l'intégrité physique
des voyous et c'est une inversion des
valeurs c'est à dire on reçoit des
projectiles et on doit concis à
l'intégrité physique à ne pas faire
tomber un individu comme auprès de la
loire alors qu'ils sont tous comme
alcoolisées donc ça c'est une vraie
inversion des valeurs et vous dire que
si on était dans un état où la police
était forte ou la justice était vraiment
répressive et ben on ferait juste un
appel à une version je peux vous dire
que s'ils savent que ça va choper 6,5 y
aura des réceptions et ben tout le monde
se dispersera mais effectivement il ya
un tel laxisme aujourd'hui que le simple
citoyen et y en a assez d'être
verbalisés pour un match trop bas ou
deux kilomètres heure mais ce que j b
quand je vois six voyous jeté des
projectiles sur la police
et ben pourquoi pas moi et ben voilà
donc ce laxisme de la voilà le résultat
que ça donne ça fait des morts ça c'est
des mains arrachées mais en tout cas
c'est out
dans le miroir parce que les forces de
l'ordre sont ont été impeccables
hier on est quand même cinq blessés chez
les gendarmes bon ça on n'en parle pas
ça intéresse personne des gendarmes mais
si c'est presque normal
maintenant faut prendre ses
responsabilités quand on voit une
grenade de désencerclement on n'a pas la
prendre
donc toutes les mains arrachées que ça
soit des gilet jaune ou s'assoit sur ce
commet ce genre d' émeutes eh ben je
suis désolé mais quand on veut ramasser
une grenade qu'un policier a jeté ses
convois l'a relancé sur les policiers
dont on comprend sa responsabilité
tout simplement on fait des conneries va
maintenant les assume ce soir il y a
donc comme neige abderrazak le disait
une marche en hommage à steve est
autorisée donc 18h 20h30 non autorisée
est ce que clairement vous craignez à
nouveau des violences seront aussi mal
je vois des jeunes avec avec de l'alcool
ce qui n'est pas autorisé ben je ne sais
pas quelle décision sera prise en haut
lieu
en tout cas oui à mon avis ça va mal se
passer de toute façon parce qu'ils vont
attendre qu'il fasse tout pour jeter des
projectiles et provoqué dans les
mortiers c'est devenu à la mode 2d banc
lui ça fasse maintenant l'extrême gauche
cocktails molotov voilà on va voir si
l'on peut parler du show sous pente ou
en tout cas j'espère que j'aurai pas de
blessés de mon côté parce que nous au
syndicat france police position colère
on ne se préoccupe plus de l'intégrité
physique de nos collègues on a beaucoup
de blessés
on a des mois donc maintenant dans la
has et donc que ces gens là prennent
leurs responsabilités s'ils veulent
affronter la police et s'il ya des
dégâts avec se regardent dans une glace
merci bruno nataf président fondateur du
collectif touche pas à mon fric d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur arte france